use the information use the given
information to make a logical conclusion
if possible if a logical conclusion is
not possible choose no logical
conclusion possible
all right so let's see what they tell us
so the statement is if i go to practice
today then i will play in the game
tomorrow so if i go this statement is
saying look if i go to practice today
then i'm definitely going to play in the
game tomorrow
and then they say i will not play in the
game
tomorrow well i just said that if i go
to practice day i'm gonna play in that
game and i said i'm not playing in that
game so i must not be going to practice
today if because if if i went i would
play so i did not go
to practice
so that let's do a couple more of these
you okay so the same same instructions
if william misses the bus
then he will be late for school
william is late for school
so let's think about this a little bit
if william misses the bus then he will
be late for school william is late for
school so missing the bus is one way
that you could be late for school but he
might have not missed the bus he might
have he might have uh caught the bus but
then didn't didn't you know kind of sat
in the bus once he got to school so
missing the bus is one of the ways that
he has he could be late for school but
it's not the only way he could be late
for school they just say if he misses
the bus then he is late for school
now if they said he is not late for
school then you know that he didn't miss
the bus because if he did he would he
would have been late but there's many
ways to be late not just missing the bus
so we don't know for a fact that william
definitely missed the bus
let's do a few more of these
if a ray bisects an angle so let's put
that angle in two then it creates two
congruent angles all right
if there are two congruent angles
then the two angles have the same
measure
all right so this this one's a little
bit more hairy so let's see if a ray
bisects an angle then it creates two
congruent angles yep okay i can i can
buy that in fact that is definitely true
if there are two congruent angles then
the two angles have the same measure
okay i can buy that as well
if a ray bisects an angle then the two
angles have the same measure so let's
see so this first sentence says if a ray
bisects an angle then it creates two
congruent angles but then the next one
says if there are two congruent angles
then the two angles have the same
measure
so if a ray bisects an angle there's two
congruent angles
which by which the next sentence tells
us that they that the two angles have
the same measure and that's the
statement here if a ray bisects an angle
then the two angles have the same
measure you might say wait wait how is
this you know different look in the
first sentence it says the
ray bisecting an angle creates two
congruent angles so we don't know yet
what congruent angle means the next
sentence says if if there are two
congruent angles then the two angles
have the same measure so the second
sentence lets us know that two congruent
angles must have the same measure so now
we can kind of merge these two together
to say if a ray bisects an angle then it
creates two angles that have the same
measure which is this choice right over
here